this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Thursday
November the 10th live from New York
it's UFC 281. feel the heat of the
octagon with DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC we got a tremendous card this week
we got Israel the Sonia against that
[__] lunatic [__] kickboxer
Peretti or whatever his name is let me
tell you something there's going to be
action all [__] night my eight my
Chinese queen is fighting listen new
customers we don't care you can bet five
dollars on UFC 281 and if your fighter
wins you get 200 and free bets who's
better than DraftKings nobody not enough
action for you out there what we got we
got a hundred percent boost with
DraftKings stepped up ballets when
DraftKings gives you a boost you're
getting paid late in parlayed
cocktuckers place of parlay today with
three or more picks and combine multiple
bets like which fighter will win total
rounds like I said to you I like uh
perea and I like the Asian girl that's
fighting I'm bad with names draft kid
sports book is the only place your Uncle
Joey bets on the UFC so do me a favor
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
today use promo code Joey and throw down
five dollars on UFC 281 and get 200 and
free bets if your fighter wins tonight
we got football I don't know if you know
that [__] we got the [__] Prime
Edition game so download the DraftKings
Sportsbook at enter code Joey and get
your [__] [__] together remember
DraftKings the official sports betting
partner UFC minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details the joint is also brought to you
by CBD lion when it comes to CBD there's
no one better than the [__]
line how do I know because they've been
working on Uncle Joey for years you know
I'm a broken down old man so do
yourselves a favor go to cbdline.com
right now and read the third party lab
results they're going to make your pubic
ass [__] curl up right now putting
code Joey church or joint and I'm gonna
give you 20 off your first order and
that includes the Delta eight gummies
which will [__] knock you around and
they have a Delta eight things you
[__] that goes straight to the
[__] root so go to CBD line right now
at the code Joey joined the church and
get 20 off let's get this [__]
party started on a Thursday
laughs
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Wednesday or Thursday the 10th or
11th who gives a [__] it's a great day
it's a whole new [__] week Cain
Velazquez is out of jail for you [__]
real people that uh would take matters
into your own hands it's a feather and a
cap for us this week I mean dog when I
found out he was in jail like he got out
I forgot he was in jail like I had
forgotten all about it's been named
Velasquez but my man my guest today is
my man Todd one of the owners of Stoners
uh Club I started with Todd about two
months ago a friend of mine [__] yeah a
friend of mine from patreon reached out
to me and said to take a look it was a
guy from patreon oh nice a guy named
sore rev good boy shout out to sorev
shout out to sorev and I ordered and uh
you know Dez came and oh yeah I was
blown the [__] away tell us how you got
this [__] started because it's a
great story all right so
[Music]
um
so for I I spoke this [__] into
existence Joey to be honest even my girl
says the same thing for for about three
years all I kept thinking about was when
weed goes legal I'm gonna I want to
focus on the delivery and I want to be
the Uber of weed everyone's gonna try to
open retail and grow and this I want to
be to because if I can control that then
the dispensaries need me the
Distributors and everyone's gonna need
my services so what I did is is is I so
happened it was during the pandemic so I
got the hell out of Queens Queens turned
the [__] and I'm like you know what I'm
going back home
um I'm gonna I'm gonna get me a nice
little house get out of the city I had a
dog at the time and it was definitely
fake because no sooner I moved back in
September January it was it was legal in
Jersey it went on the it went on the
ballot in November and it went on how
Jersey legalized it they put it on as a
referendum which meant that it goes it's
one once it got voted in on November and
November it goes on to the Constitution
that it becomes our constitutional right
now to consume and possess cannabis in
New Jersey
so once I saw that I was like okay we
can't sell it but we can gift it so I I
kind of uh did some research on a DC
model where they sell stickers and they
gift you the Cannabis because it's
decriminalized in the zone of DC so they
found a loophole around it
um so I went with that I went you know
it was on the Constitution there was our
legal right so I started creating the
website on January 2nd by January 15th
over launched January 16th and we
launched as a Statewide service from the
beginning so
um I didn't want to I didn't want to
focus on one area and be known as oh
that person in that area I was like you
know what let's tackle the whole state
from the beginning so in the beginning
it was just me driving I had four orders
on our first day so once I saw full
orders on our first day I looked at my
girlfriend my business partner shout out
to Sherry I love you baby uh I said
we're going to be successful this is it
like we made the [__] right move like
this is it this is what we're going to
be doing and she was still working her
regular job at the time so every day a
little bit more order coming in baby can
I quit baby can I quit I want to come
work I I want to do this full-time and I
remember one day dropping her off to
work and I was like you know what go in
and tell them you quit we're good let's
focus on this and we were literally
driving from High Point New Jersey all
the way down to Atlantic City and one
day two hours and 45 minutes and and one
trip and we were smiling the whole time
because I'm like I was like I couldn't
believe I had a customer
in the top of New Jersey and one in the
you know and all the way down south so
it just grew from there so and then uh
news articles started picking us up and
that's what really
put us in on to the next level so yeah
and then it's just been a blessing from
there you know we just now when we met
you were telling me that Jersey was
messing with you yeah I mean we're still
dealing with a with an issue in Jersey
so
um we had a previous company
um slump kitchen
where they served a cease and desist
based on a Consumer Fraud so we answered
the cease and desist as best as we could
but they wanted personal I'm gonna be
honest they wanted customer information
that we weren't prepared to give up we
felt like we had an obligation to our
customers to protect their identity
privacy right so
um so we fought them and we're now we're
still fighting them in court I still
have to you know lawyer fees they don't
paying every day um because I feel we're
still right and and uh they they offered
us a settlement and we denied it based
on the stipulations in the settlement I
didn't like how it was worded and I I
thought it was going to be a sideways
setup so I told my lawyer just we'll see
him in court let the let this because
now it's all the way up to the Supreme
Court we appealed it that we kept losing
losing losing we kept appealing it like
I'm not gonna stop fighting to the to
the fight is over you know what I mean
like you didn't [__] them [__] them yeah
like and then what and then it's not
[__] you know I don't want to go to you
know I do want to play nice but it's if
you're going to come out me legally I'm
going to defend myself legally that's
the only way that I that's the only
recourse that I had so
um
so yeah we we dealt with that and and
then now here we are at Stoner club and
and we're revamped and better than ever
and you know you know I never
one of my dear friends I mean he's a
great guy in La his name is Gino and he
owns speedweed okay and you know I knew
Gino from the store kind of sort of and
he'd always for me like I was always I
like going to the store yeah for me
going to the store was like
you know going I don't listen I hate
[__] shopping yeah like I went
sneaker shop with my daughter yesterday
walked in there you got five [__]
minutes you got five dude I'm the
opposite I love it I can't I can't sit
in the store for two hours yeah even
when I shop if you see how I shop you go
[__] I'd rather go in take a pair of
jeans and a t-shirt get the [__] out of
there If It Don't Fit I'll come back
I don't want to deal with it I don't
want to be changing and yeah yeah I got
underwear I don't look like changing
room I don't do the fitting thing either
I get I get the stuff I think I need If
It Don't Fit we'll bring it back yeah it
might be two or three months but it's
coming I'm on the inside when I go into
a place I know what I want I do the
research yeah so I'm in the night I'm
not your typical Shopper my like people
are like oh we shop eight hours a day
you got the wrong [__] but for
me I really enjoyed
walking into the weed store and and I
saw the process get better in L.A like I
remember them opening and I would not go
wild wild west days no no I would not go
okay I refused what was the what was the
reason just my issue was in the
beginning the doors were going to get
kicked in and no my issues were in the
beginning that
I grew up smoking weed in New York
[__] City you know and I know
what like that was going into the city
as a child to get a bag of dope was one
of the funnest things absolutely you
could ever [__] do in your life from
the hot dog to the Carvel shake to the
movie theater it was amazing to this
that it's an exciting thing it's very
exciting to go on a corner or in a car
in a place you're not you don't belong
like they're like they'll even ask you
what the [__] are you doing they know
that a lot like I was telling you on
Wednesdays in 1993 we used to go into
the Bronx because it was free joint day
on Jerome Avenue free joint day on
Jerome Avenue
93 and you could [__] drive your car
and you'd be a hundred Jersey cars yeah
100 [__] Pennsylvania cars and the
cops would pull me over once in a while
and you really had no Escape because if
they pulled you over here you are in
Spanish Harlem with four white kids yeah
what are you doing here my grandmother
your grandmother don't live in [__]
speak all of them get it together so
what's her address but that was New York
City like I always tell a story I'm a
Catholic [__] I believe that
Jesus the whole [__] thing okay as
I've gotten older you know whatever but
when I was a kid I really [__]
believed in Jesus and the whole [__]
thing I grew up Catholic too what burned
me the most when I was about the summer
of eighth grade going into freshman year
I remember this like it was yesterday A
friend of mine Lefty said I got a new
spot in the village for weed and we went
to the Village parked the car walked
like two blocks and it was the bottom of
a [__] church I could live to I'm a
hundred and I'll never forget that it
was the creepy thing you walk downstairs
to the bingo hall it was in the [__]
bingo hall and they'd have you know
Little Nickel bags 20 bags quarter
rounds and it was like you know like 10
feet of a table yeah and you could go
and they sold this [__] they sold they
got weed and they put it in a block oh
the brick the bricks like this big and
they dip it in hash oil for 35 bucks oh
yeah but I never seen that when I see
the big shitty weed no these are these
bricks and they're probably what should
he weep but when they dipped it in that
hash and then they baked it or some [__]
[__] and you got to cut it with a
scissor this is when I was here and I
never forget that was the same week I
went to see the [__] police at cbgb's
saying Roxanne with a [__] stolen ID
my friend goes come on use my brother's
ID so that whole week I was like blown
away I'm 14 at cbgb's and now I'm buying
weed at the bottom of a [__] church
and I was fine with it I was happy until
I saw the priest come down and somebody
gave him like an envelope they say thank
you God bless you I'm like
holy [__] but again as Blasphemous is
the sound it was exciting to me yeah
it's exciting I liked you know there's
something about getting paid on Friday
for me getting you a little [__] 200
paycheck as a kid and cashing it and
running to the drug dealer's house and
putting a half pounds in the trunk of
your car and driving knowing the cops
might blow me over that was that little
thing so for that reason when the
licensing came to California
I wasn't in yeah I was like this ain't
for me I'm gonna mind my business but
then they started popping up with
lollipops yeah
with [__] and I'm like wait a second I
think it's time to go down there the
licenses the licenses were
350. and you know how much money I had
in my bank account 18. 18 then one day
through the grace of God red band called
me and he goes what are you doing I
don't know he goes we're going to
Houston's to eat Rogan's taking us to
that special day because you there was
like at that time there were like eight
doctors that were giving out licenses
but there was one guy that would go to
court with you like he had a reputation
that he had gone to court with you that
he fought the cops in fact they even
threw him in jail oh sure day so Rogan
went specifically to him
paid for our licenses and I went to this
[__] uh weed store called the
pharmacy the pharmacy and it was 10
years ahead of its time ice cream but
guess what and I got no reason to lie
every time I walk in there I walked out
of there my 430 went on my Visa card wow
I was dropping four to five hundred I'll
get my wife down here to tell you she
had to sit me down and go
you put five thousand dollars
remember in a month on a bad day for me
oh that was in a month on your Visa card
damn
a bad day for me was 200. yeah like that
was like a dad I got like a quarter
because you didn't act up in that [__]
like I'm not gonna okay like my first
experience with going into a dispensary
is when I took a recent trip to
California I went into cookies I went
into med man I just wanted to see
um and I I found myself I want this I
want this then they give you limits oh
no you can only buy two of these or
three of these but then you're like okay
give me this and you want the cards and
they're like let me show you this and
then you get wrapped up in this world
you know what I mean it's like the
experience is so [__] cool and I I
ended up with a bunch of [__] that I
didn't even I don't even think we
finished before we left give it away
then you just give it away I know people
like that every time I come to New York
they'd have like [__] the best was a
THC inhaler oh for a while 35 for a
Nathan an inhaler and uh I I enjoyed all
that [__] but again it didn't do nothing
after a while you're just buying little
gadgets and [__] yeah and then like
after you get hip you're like I'm just
buying [__] flowers yeah yeah I'm not
coming here by nothing else and but at
the same time I used to get calls from
people going Gino will deliver weed to
you he really likes you he's your friend
he's a fan and I'm like I like Gina
Gino's my bro but it's not for me I
don't want to get us delivery yeah at my
house and that's not what it is and it's
nine o'clock at night and then we're
gonna have a different problem exactly
let me just go down there but
I started talking Gino would go to The
Comedy Store on Tuesdays and his
specialty with these blunts with high
level exotic weed and a glass tip oh
like the Packers they got out now
I'm not a big pack not a Packwood fan
yeah I didn't think so that's better
that [__] burns my lungs too much man
it's too much you know what it is it's
the [__] Packwood I've never liked
packwoods when I lived in Florida I had
this roommate I'm not gonna say his name
but he smoked the shittiest weed out of
the shittiest dirtiest backwards you can
find I'm like he'd look through the pack
like nah not dirty enough no no I'm like
dog I'm not smoking that [__] like we're
in a time of like Kryptonite back then
it was like you know Silver Line Haze
all this good shit's coming on I'm like
dog I'm not smoking that with you but
that was like his thing he loved it he
loved choking I'm like yeah
he grinded it in a Mr Coffee grinder it
got real real real
yeah like yeah so um yeah it was
disgusting it's just [__] crazy how
how much the weed like I was seeing
something the other day on TV they're
predicting it to be in the billions now
you know you cannot fathom that we got
to see today like we heard about it for
a long time yeah weed is coming weed's
gonna be legal I mean I started hearing
this in the sixth grade yeah yeah you've
been hearing it forever I watched uh I
watched the thing on 60 Minutes Or 2020
in the sixth grade that tobacco
companies had already bought tons of
weed and they were just waiting in
[__] feelings I heard Phillip Morris
Philip Morris Morris went crazy went
crazy and now they're talking about
they're going to now they're an
anti-tobacco get the [__] out of here
you just killed people for hundreds of
years you know what I'm saying I don't
I don't agree with that [__] you know
now you want to now you wanna like try
to clean up the mess that you caused you
know what I mean like it's like when
Exxon spills the oil and says oh no but
we'll clean it up most these aren't you
know what I mean yeah you got yeah you
got to clean it up but I love the
delivery the first delivery service I
have ordered from was you yeah really I
swear to God and that's what so I'm
telling you swear to God [__] loves
you bro like oh I love Dez
you know she usually she's very quiet
very reserved she just talk like tells
me what what I need you know what I need
to know she came in she's like you know
Joe he did it's like of course we all
she's like he's a customer he's amazing
he he loves us and he wants to speak to
you and but I was like holy [__] like
Joey Diane like I was [__] impressed
really awesome I was very impressed and
then like I got you know I have 2 200
milligram Edibles yeah if not any time
any place you take those there's only
one is that the one you gave him yeah
you gave him like a leg he said you dude
did he have to be carried out of here so
he couldn't no we were in L.A oh you
were in L.A he left he had to leave the
park he left he just left I love Paulie
I shout out the police he's in New York
this week really okay
I met Paulie Shore when he was doing the
MTV Beach House years ago it was just
him and that BJ Jesse Jesse oh my God
years ago and I see and I'm one I'm like
get the [__] out of here and I'm like
Paul you know how everyone's doing back
in the day so he's like yo come on bro
like and he's like and he's like what do
you know and back then there was no cell
phones no pictures it was just well I
[__] you're funny as hell I love you
yeah I think he's doing a show tonight
yeah yeah wow after the podcast yeah
we'll see what the [__] is that that's
[__] awesome he's a good dude I like
Paulie a lot I love Paulie you know
Paulie and Paulie's like East I know
what Paul he's like right now he lost
his mom uh about four years ago and
Paulie and me got tighter
mom died you know because she was good
to me so yeah and he's in Vegas he's
still crazy and everybody's got a
podcast I'm so like I'm glad to see he's
back doing [__] again he never went away
you know really because I haven't seen
him for a while you know listen the
movie stop calling well yeah that that
stopped well you you know that was the
80s and early night so [__] you you know
you go on your runs and and you know
when your run is over it's like look at
Van Damme look at all it's over there's
nothing you can do about it no you can
do nothing you can do about reinvent
yourself and you know do the best you
can that's all you can do move forward
but uh you know it's uh what I've seen
with reefer has been
I'm Blown Away insane I am really the
last 10 years to speed
the speed I saw that caught up you know
I saw
a weed store pop-up two wheat stores pop
up and then just in my neighbor I
remember I was telling my wife the other
day she went to Tennessee one Christmas
this had to be 2010.
2009 [__] Christmas Eve I go upstairs
to my box
and there's a half of joy
and I'm like what the [__] am I gonna do
it's eight o'clock it's Christmas Eve
and I ain't got no [__] weed
I just got in the car I went to my weed
store closed I went to any ones that I
knew that were closed and then I found
one and I went in there and they had all
right stuff it was just one girl by
herself and she was very sweet and she
goes you know I have to work till 10 so
I gave her like a 20 tip of being there
but then as I walked out of there I saw
another weed store right across the
street and I go let me go in there let's
see what they got guys this is gonna
shock you I walked in there like welcome
Merry Christmas and I'm like you guys
are still open yeah we're open till 10.
come on in and they gave me it you got
to fill this out they gave me like a
sheet you know name address but on the
bottom when I signed it said this
establishment is owned by The Church of
Jesus Christ Calabasas or something like
that I'm not making it like I don't know
where Calabar I don't know if it was in
Calabasas the comedy uh the weed store
was in North Hollywood but when I signed
it and I saw
this is owned by the church of whatever
in Calabasas and I looked at the guy oh
you guys got churches because yeah we
own like three of them we figured the
church could use the money the pastor is
open-minded yeah you definitely get some
taxes and the weed was all right but
just to let you know that that's what
was there and then like I went back
there two months later and the Christian
Store was gone and the store across the
street with the girl had become
a mega store really so she took off so
she so she she was just working yeah
what I'm saying but their their company
they and they ended up controlling that
they [__] their products sound I guess
then we went from the pharmacy that was
the hot spot in Santa Monica at the
pharmacy yeah you truly the one that
oh my God kushmart started we started
with kushmart in a little apartment
you've been in a cookie store out in L.A
no no they're like the I we the one we
went in was it
it was like the Apple
right I can't deal with that no that's
not for me no so what's your type of
store that you want I want to deal with
you yeah one but I call it listen a
personal experience like someone with a
person always like they I call this
white people [__] okay okay there's
there's weed people and but now they're
trying to enter the white world into it
Hi how are you with an iPad we're like a
white gloves okay and they're like how
do you and then you go up to the glass
and you pick the strain and then she
pushes it into the computer and then you
have to go to a window
yeah yeah that's too high-tech for me
that's what one of the stores I was
tight with they went that route okay I'm
done so what's your ideal so your ideal
dispensary my ideal dispenser is a
two-man operation okay put a waiting
room out there and put two people in for
two people you got five minutes if
you're gonna come and ask me creepy
questions hi I want a weed that makes my
fits my feet stink and my [__] hurt and
my eyeballs and I don't really want to
be high but listen [__] yeah we
sell the devil here okay we sell the
devil here we don't sell money
see the [__] customer request that we
get oh it's a nightmare it's a nightmare
I I don't need it that high THC
it's like yeah I can't [__] help you
I can come in with the [__]
Adventures I want something that will
take me there but my eyes can't get
ready
you know I can't I can't get higher I
can't get in New York now they've what I
like about New York's weed system is
that they've hired a pharmacy and the
medical marijuana stores there's a
pharmacy
yeah so when you go in go give them the
[__] ear beat yeah and then when they
decide they'll give it to a Salesman and
let him get you a week to get the people
out that's when people come in like I
got anxiety neck pain back pain and
that's when there's literally strains
that do work well for certain ailments
um but yeah but when you go into like a
you know a recreational dispensary
they're not trying to hear that [__]
like I try to appease like my customer
service we try to appease much as we can
but I mean we get crazy requests like I
wanted half CBD half THC I'm like well
you tell me where the [__] they make
that at because I have no no it's it's
crazy when I find it I'll let you know
but that's pretty give me the old
geezers that smoke pot oh I don't want
this [__] new behind
you know I bought the weed it was 24 it
was too strong for me but then I bought
the 16 it wasn't listening yeah here at
the store we saw the devil yeah okay I
don't know what people ask us a lot why
why uh a question that comes up is why
why don't we announce our THC levels I
said well first of all we don't actually
test our THC levels so it would just be
an estimate anyway so I'd rather like
not put that information out you know
what I mean like if you want to look for
an estimate you can Google it and get an
estimate like on that stream but I got I
got a brother who I love daily
we grew up together he's my boy we
smoked tons of weed together if I get a
bag I call him if he gets a bat I call
him
every time I give him weed
it's
20 call [__] Adventure
you know and I'm not that guy like I'm
not that guy like so he'll come over
here and I'll give him the weed he
doesn't understand
that and it's hard to tell people that I
know you like Silver Surfer or silver
what's the stuff you just gave me oh
silver haze okay everybody likes sober
Hayes but
some people at some of these stores they
Market the names by the clientele
no disrespect to anybody I had a friend
that was a [__] writer and he became
a millionaire selling weed in the ghetto
areas Long Beach like the real low areas
you should have seen the names he had
for those things like welfare he had a
bunch of [__] names that I'm like why
do you give them those he's the one that
told me goes I get fired breath here but
I I won't sell fire breath I'll sell
lunar eclipse
this neighborhood calls for a lunar
eclipse when they see lunar eclipse they
come in oh my God you know and that so
you understand me so whenever he comes
here and I give him a weed like he'll go
on
it says here like you know the white
truffle is a sativa listen
leave me the [__] alone you know what
I'm saying just smoke the weeds just
smoke the weed what do you give a [__]
what the name is they don't you're not
gonna get that in L.A they mix them up
there's a few people will go yeah this
is strawberry cloth well this is real
old school [__] diesel but besides
that they switch them so when people
come up to go what do you think about
the New York Diesel where'd you get it
from I smoked it when I was in
California well I don't know what you're
talking about because what they gave you
probably wasn't even diesel yeah it was
Jack Herer yeah yeah it was a Jack Herer
which don't do [__] to me yeah oh you
don't like exactly
that weed has never done anything to me
really
special I've got all sativa don't work
for them it's a certain sativa like the
silver haze
what about the sour I gave you that's
the sour I don't even think I tasted
that yet oh all right yeah that's that's
on another level that's the Exotic sour
okay and we got that's our state that's
one of our that's our state we know our
New York customers love um you know and
they love it sativa
if we don't have sativa on our menu
people our sales stagnate man like we
need to keep like it's it and if we
don't have it we get calls where's my
sativa where's my city because you got
to understand we have a lot of working
moms working parents and they want that
they don't want to be locked on the
couch they need to go take a couple
puffs and then go take care of the kids
and cook dinner or go to work you know
and do that daily [__] and I love
sativas during the day and I love I
smoke everything though like I smoke 20
times a day at the at the at the low end
you know what I mean I just want to see
the devil right when I pulled back and I
smoke
it's to get high absolutely it's to get
[__] stalled I don't want to get
medium stoned or you know if you if you
don't want your eyes to get red by
Visine I don't know what the [__] to
tell you but that's the only problem
with the weed store that if I my ideal
weed store I want to talk to my guy okay
I want to see the weed yeah for sure um
you know I don't want to put my hands on
it but let me smell it I want to listen
I want to be part of that you know and
that's what I enjoyed about the whistle
to be honest with you I'm unemployed in
the daytime so I got 30 minutes to go in
a weed store yeah I don't have 30
minutes to go dick around you know but I
have 30 minutes to go in a weed store
and then suddenly goes I got something
in the back for you you know let me show
you what's in the back because I dog
they used to be like
so the funny thing is that the valley is
a little bit
more like for us like for people who are
talking people you know there was a
store in the valley that was open till
two wow they didn't give a [__] about
the cops or nothing but as you get
closer to Hollywood it gets very woke
and it was woke years ago I used to go
to the store just to torture them they
were woke chicks you know all right all
that [__] they went to yoga you know I
like these they put they put pretty
girls in there and I appreciate a pretty
girl selling me weed absolutely but
these girls don't know about weed I'd
get them High by blowing a cigarette in
their face so when you go in there
they're telling you the wrong
information I don't want that I want
somebody who gets down you gotta get
down so [__] we came to get down okay
my first requirement is if you're gonna
sell me weed you need to consume and you
smoke some [__] weed you need to [__]
you need to know what you're talking
like when people ask me I could tell you
what this does what that does why I
smoke this why I smoke you know I I like
I I educate I'm a straight nerd though I
love you know like I said me too I like
looking at them
the only thing I can get my hands on was
that was that Mexican squished up brick
weed with and I thought to me that was
the best [__] thing on earth and then
the the first good bud that came to my
neighborhood was Hydro when I was like
14 and like that was on a whole there's
no seeds I was like holy [__] where's
the seeds how they grow more plants you
know what I mean but um yeah and then
just to see where weed has evolved man
it's amazing it's it's gonna get even
stronger even stronger and these nerds I
mean you know I never saw uh
this thing with the blow torch and [__]
oh oh the dead I never saw it I dropped
you off no no we have our own uh I don't
dab okay I'm gonna tell you the reason
why I stopped and and because like you
said I'm a flower guy and and some and
I'm not really even a big pen guy but I
found these sauce bars that I really
really love I was gonna bring you some
because they're amazing they're they're
really good
um but
dabs to me like they it's too [__]
much you know what I'm saying like all
that and like there's be there'll be
times I'm like oh that was cool like I'm
just high but then I'll take that same
dad my [__] head will start my chest
and I feel like I gotta take my shirt
off I'm like nah I don't need to like go
to outer space I just want to get high
chill out watch a movie eat some [__]
dinner you know what I'm saying like
play with the pups you know what I mean
like I don't I don't I don't need to be
like oh it's wiping sweat and now I
don't feel good now I'm not enjoying
that [__] at all so I don't do the I
don't do the dabs you know what I mean I
don't not anymore I like left there I
did one I did a few of them yeah
absolutely I'm hoping you got it you
gotta try it and then when that I was at
the Improv and these [__] they
used to make the Lord's groomers or
Manos
300 milligram gummies that were [__]
[__] up I mean they would they
I still talk to these guys because
they're like related to a friend of mine
and uh we were at The Improv and these
[__] set up a rig right on
Melrose Boulevard I'm like holy [__]
right in front of a [__] restaurant
with valets and Lamborghinis and we're
out there with a blowtorch it hit me it
hit me to the point where whenever I
take a good hit like a the freeze pipe
my bong whatever I take a good hit you
know it rattles you a little bit you
drink some water or whatever this [__]
just took me out then I thought I was
gonna pass out and I'm like you know
what man I don't need this business when
it's time to smoke this I'll just go get
heroin
I'll just go get a patch a little bag of
heroin and stuff snorting heroin you
can't listen there's no way you're
tolerant you know I'm saying like
there's no [__] night like it's just
too much it you know I like my I'm an
old Diamond you look at the you look at
the the strength the the testing 97 Tac
dog I don't need I don't know I mean
it's good no not what I do like I'm not
gonna lie what I do like is the hash I
do like crinkling up the hash and
throwing it on a on a blunt actually
it's kind of I'm kind of like bougie
with this [__] like I can't it's like I
almost like I can't smoke it now without
without some of the ice water hash or
you know what I mean now
again I bought hash 40 [__] years ago
and I smoked a lot when I went to San
Francisco
I went to I tried hashing all those weed
stores and I think out of the 30 hashes
I got I found one good hash you ever get
the Hella danks or or the from us
under a glass
yeah okay so I put on the pin all the
hash you get today you light it and it
just melts yeah that's not good that's
not the hash I grew up on okay I grew up
with mash from over there with the stamp
yeah Platinum the gold and the [__]
Silverstone and I'll never forget buying
a 35 piece and the stamp was still alive
you like that on fire and it lights
don't [__] melt oh no no it don't
melt it lights don't melt it has the
lights okay if your last Heights I got
it I don't know if I bring I don't know
if I grabbed the hash I know I grabbed
some some of the concentrates for you
because we just got the custom
um our own custom Stoner Club so we're
trying to Brand every so we're trying to
Brand everything we're trying to partner
with people who already have these
facilities who make great products and
we're trying to um collaborate with them
um you know and bring our ideas to the
table and and also create a line of
Stoner Club you know branded products
that you know that are top top quality
that everyone
um would enjoy and Rave about you got
some great [__] refund and your
Edibles like I ordered Des came and I
was going I always go on Sundays I go to
my buddy's house to watch football
obviously I went over there once I
brought the 200 milligrams and they
weren't biting yeah yeah no I got some
true dose I go because they're lower
they're not they're lower doses when I
first got true no it's like oh these
ain't for me yeah yeah exactly bring
them around the corner so I went around
the corner I'm busting that balls I
think it was the I love the [__] uh
Starburst I love those those are my the
pink Stars will [__] you up oh boy so I
had like two the whole bag is 300 guys a
legit three legit I took 15 I gave it to
one of my buddies and I gave the other
guy another buddy guys I have no reason
why nobody I was talking maybe I went to
get a pizza and when I checked on both
of them their eyes will [__] beat red
but they need heavy smoke heavy smokers
yeah they smoke you know laughing gas
every week and [__] nice so I'm like oh
[__] and then the guy is usually a
yeller [__] you drop the ball what type
of [__] yeah
this [__] hasn't said a word
like if it's like if it's healing is
cheering he'll go give me some [__] you
know and all that [__] he's a wild man
and I get look at my little brother you
this [__] up he's like wow right in
front of him I opened up the bag and I
ate the 270 milligrams right in front of
them right in front of Michael when I do
[__] like that people are like oh my god
get the bet yo we need to pump his thumb
like though I eat Edibles like I eat
Edibles and I love the turtles but go
ahead finish the show oh my God I came
home that night I was [__] up I love
when I am I call them uh
okay I love having accents I love having
accidents by mistake like like just a
little accident you eat one too much but
you're by yourself yeah and you're kind
of embarrassed to tell people Doug yeah
you know you know people like I can't
eat them yeah like dog I got a story for
you you know what I'm saying everybody
got an animal dog
and I still remember being in my old
house and just like control like my wife
and a friend were in the other room and
I was eating pirate booty I'll never
forget that and I just kept shoving it
in my mouth when I was like maybe 2 000
milligrams Edibles maybe 18 bong hits a
mushroom for flavor and I got home and
they were waiting for flavor oh yeah you
gotta do a little Mushroom in there
absolutely I started [__] eating and
I mean my wife would say to me she goes
I don't know what you do but when I wake
up in the mornings the kitchen is like a
[__] bomb there's ham out there's
cheese you ate 10 apples I'm trying to
you know
try not to [__] be a slob so you
start you know Weight Watchers tell you
if you're not hungry enough for an apple
you ain't really hungry okay so I'll do
one apple if the apples are really good
I'm like [__] yeah I eat another Apple
then you eat another I didn't know that
I didn't know that was like a Weight
Watchers yeah yeah apples so if you
[__] once I eat three or four apples
if the reef is winning it's done there's
no Weight Watchers everything goes out
the window there's no points yeah and
just go For Broke you know and uh
but that night with the true dose I was
like 300 milligrams you tried the
chocolates and then I started getting
the chocolate tonight I started getting
the punch bars but I was getting the
punch bars yeah they've been around
they've been around for a while but it
was really surprising like uh
how professional your drivers were they
were on time they hit you with a text
and tell you when they're going to be
there when you wake up in the morning
you know you just [__] order it at
night like whenever I know whenever I'm
doing a show in the city I don't I have
a bag of a 200 milligram metal but tell
them you can't give those some in New
York no no no that's what I'm saying
you'll end up in [__] Delaware yeah
yeah yeah yeah tell these guys your
schedules like one day is what okay so
we we have uh we have a weekly promotion
schedule that you can go to
stonerclub.com and Stoner Club is with a
k
um just for anyone who
um but yeah so so Monday we call it
Manic Monday Monday is I believe you get
15 off every order over 200. so and it's
automatically applied you don't have to
use a coupon code
um Tuesday is toke Tuesday which is 10
off flour Edibles
um and I believe pre-rolls
um Wednesday was called hash Wednesday
at one point and we were giving a good
discount on our on our concentrates but
we changed it to um we were giving away
pre-rolls so for every 100 hours you
spend on Wednesday you get a free
pre-roll with your order I think it's we
cap it at 10. so if you spend a thousand
dollars it'll come with 10 free
pre-rolls
um Thursday is called slurs day that's
where we get a tampered that's where
we're speaking of Edibles that's where
you get 10 off all your Edibles drinks
um and things like that we may
we may revamp that and look back at that
special and then Friday's Freaky Friday
which is a mystery giveaway or promotion
so it's what I decide when I wake up in
the morning like what we're doing like
we'll collaborate the night before and
we'll say hey
um you know we have
extra Edibles or we have these Edibles
we can give like we'll we'll collaborate
and see
um something that we haven't done in a
while like if we give away Edibles on
Friday uh you know a couple times that
month we'll think of you know something
else sometimes we'll give away merch
sometimes we'll just announce just a 20
off everything on the site
um and then Saturday or Saturday which
is 10 off yeah which is 10 off all the
concentrates
um and I do we I think we added the
pre-rolls on there too because we have
the hash infused pre-roll so
um and then Sunday is Sunday fun day
which is 10 off the entire store mom no
cap
and then yeah I already explained what
Monday is
um but we're also going to implement
um some other giveaways and contests
like if you leave a Google review on our
Google my business once a month we draw
a winner from that and we give them a
free ounce But it includes free delivery
and it's top shelf
um so um it's incentivized and you can
leave an honest review like you could
you could win leaving a one star review
now I'm gonna respond to you and find
out why it's a one star and try to fix
it but you know everyone everyone's
eligible to win we're also going to
implement pretty soon I'm not sure when
but a raffling system so it's going to
be monthly based where every order comes
with a digital raffle ticket and at the
end of that month we're gonna pull it
out and then we're gonna think of a
prize for that person to win as well we
also May Implement our loyalty program
again so there's a ton of things we
um we um we love our customers like you
guys
we [__] love you guys like I like
without you guys we wouldn't be [__] and
tonight we appreciate each and every one
of you the word of mouth
um all the kind words anyone has said
for us so that's why we always listen to
the customer's feedback and we always
try I mean within means we try to answer
that that feedback customer support is
huge with us because with all these new
Services popping up
um what's going to set you apart is
customer service and let me add to this
too let me add to this
guys I don't want to sound like a
[__] snobby or something but
you know some of you just want Jersey's
a big [__] place and Jersey has bad
areas and good areas and New York City
where you're delivering now also has
good areas and bad areas and
you know I'm an older guy I don't have a
[__] born to lose t-shirt on with a
Hitler tattoo on my forehead so yeah you
know I care about my neighbors I care
about the people you know and
the most important thing like when I was
in high school when I graduated high
school a friend of mine said to me that
he goes do you know what I really do
part-time I go well he goes I deliver
Coke for a service
and that doesn't want Spanish people in
their house so white people that are
ugly white people they don't want some
brown guy coming in your house to sell
you Coke
they sent this guy this guy was a white
dude he put on a suit and Armani suit I
don't even know if that was our money
there but he looked like a [__]
probation officer this guy you know and
it worked it worked I'm not saying that
whatever he I'm not saying that these
people were prejudiced I'm just saying
that these people were attorneys you
can't send the guy in here with a
[__] tattoo and [__] hair I got an
attorney I make [__] two million a
year yeah million dollar clients I can't
have this kid come in here with slippers
thinking like you know I'm gonna tell
you something all of your deliveries and
you know I bought it 10 times one of our
biggest the [__] the delivery drivers
dressed to the teeth nines smell good
look good they talk to you the cars are
great they don't come on your block
blasting [__] music when you wake up
in the morning it says we've accepted
your order it'll be delivered wait for
the link to come up so when the link
come thumbs up will tell you you're
going to be around your area at 221. if
they're not there at 221 you'll get a
text from them at 2 8 13 telling you why
they won't be there at 221 tell you
there's some jerk off whatever that's
what I enjoyed about it the most the
professionalism from A to Z the thing I
was scared of the most was some kid
tearing on my block with a Z28 with a
gray bumper with a shot with a sign on
the card that says we got weeds we got
weed a buddy of mine called me once and
he goes do you need weed I got this
really good weed for you and it was
great the guy goes I know these guys
they're rather hey scene they'll deliver
the week yeah like okay I just need like
an eight this one like the first week I
moved here I had been in Jersey for two
weeks I had the same week you know I
thought yeah yeah you can't I never
gonna send me a box like three days
later but when I first moved here I
needed weed the guy goes I got top level
weed for you he was like a friend of a
friends
okay
he goes to delivery driver I go you want
me to tip him or anything else you could
tip him if you want you know I don't I
don't even know if this is a service
this was a guy doing me a favor yeah and
the weed was Sensational but the kid
came
he came with four [__] people in his
car
okay uh he pulled up I went outside and
when I went outside guess what they were
smoking a joint in the car and I said
thank you I gave him a 50 tip even
though the guy told me not to tip him
then the guy goes where are you going I
thought we could smoke
I go bro I got a daughter inside of
watching TV
I didn't call you to chill okay so right
away when they accept four people in the
car yeah that's [__] crazy that's
amateur damage you just amateur power
you know and all those things and and
some of the people you deal with don't
want [__] damage some people yeah
they don't give a [__] but some people
like you know what I want whoever comes
here I want them to look our customer
base they don't want they don't want
ghetto I mean I don't mean to
classifying but they don't they want you
to be yeah they want you to be
presentable okay so people my daughter
doesn't know when Des comes here she's
like who's that girl yeah well she's a
friend of mine yeah she doesn't when we
used to do the munchies it was cool
because we used to sell chips and then
give gift to Canada you know and it was
cool because the parents would like give
all the munchies to the kid they're like
okay here's your treats and then I'm
going off with mine like because and all
the kids will say oh yeah food delivery
and the parents you know and then but
when all the way I would love to do
a weed delivery service like yours
but it would be from nine o'clock to two
in the morning 9 A.M 9 p.m 9 p.m so like
in after hours yes for people who want
who want uh we're gonna we're gonna
think we're gonna expand our hours but
we want to see how how I'm not talking
about you guys I'm just giving you when
I lived in Boulder and I was not there
was no weed delivery service Colorado
right yeah it's Boulder Colorado there
was a chubby kid that would come in
every day with a smile on his face at
six in the morning I'm like why are you
smiling for he goes man I found the
[__] cookie ice cream service that
delivers till two in the morning and
they're all Stoners they bring you wheat
too this is in Boulder this is Boulder
95.
this kid was getting bigger every month
I'm like dog how'd you game this well
those cookies the cookies were [__]
Sensational they delivered them things
delivered cookies they deliver them to
you hot that's [__] and like little
pastries and ice cream treats and you
have a thing but he also brought you a
joiner too and I've always said wow
that's literally our motto yeah it's
literally oh my God but nine to two
you're welcome you're [__] gooply
gobs who thinks they're cute and they're
trying to mug you or something like that
yeah so it would have to be like uh like
you know a Massage Envy does their
packages like you have to subscribe to
them yeah you gotta have your card we
gotta have it oh yeah then you got that
info on the people yeah we'll just make
the season yeah it's like an app that's
I love all that yeah yeah I know I know
for me like I don't want like even I
used to deliver Chinese food I was
really selling Coke okay but I use the
delivery I use the Chinese food as a
thing you know how many times people
call me I said hey man can you
so I like that I like that I I know I
would if I'm sitting here at 11 o'clock
and [__] like you and I was sitting
at 11 o'clock and Blues Brothers came in
clear the field Blues Brothers coming
out 11 30. that's when I call you dog
I need any of those chocolate chip
cookies with the walnuts in them and I
need a half ounce of weed but we're fat
it's like a family delivery service and
we deliver it till two you know what I'm
saying how many [__] late night
restaurant people because they don't
have any money in the daytime they go
bus tables yeah and now they got 200 to
buy so exactly I've always loved that
not that I would love to even deliver it
not that I could even stay up till 11AM
but it's just so
that the world is endless for you
brother absolutely like you have the
World by the balls I like your Moxie and
I wish you all luck in the world and
next Wednesday if it all works out not
not yesterday next Wednesday
the first 50 orders in New York and New
Jersey I'm giving away 25 grams in New
Jersey and 25 grams of laughing gas in
New York City next Wednesday I'll have a
video up to let you know how we're going
to make it Fly [__] suckers and that's
it brother appreciate you coming up
absolutely bro I love you I just want to
take a minute
um honestly while while I'm on your
platform to absolutely thank you for
everything you've done for me bro you've
been a great friend
um your motivational speeches in the
morning sometimes have gotten me through
some bad days and I I while you're still
here I want to give you your flowers
brother and not just from me I want to
tell you I love you you know I love you
but I want to speak on behalf of
everybody else thank you that you've
touched in this world and I want to give
you a round of applause
that's the way to end the podcast on a
Thursday don't forget to visit
stonersclub.com uh they deliver in New
Jersey everywhere you want to share your
coupon code so they can say yes you want
to do it today we can do it right now
bust it okay so if you go to Stoner club
with a k.com backslash Uncle Joey You're
Gonna Save 10 on your first order and
then you're also Gonna Save five percent
on any additional order in the future if
you use or and then if you just go to
stonerclub.com and you in the coupon
code area you type in Uncle Joey you'll
still receive that 10 off and the five
percent off in the future so thank you
brother absolutely we'll take care of
our people here guys I'm a professional
Stoner and professional Stoners were
based on love man absolutely you know
when people say to me aren't you scared
smoking joints that people give you I
don't know because in my world the stone
is that I hang out with they would never
ever do something like that ever the
people I grew up with were called heads
Heads yes no drinking no nothing they
just want to see the devil every [__]
day yeah I love you [__] have a
great weekend and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack all right I
want to thank my man Mike I want to
thank my man Todd from stoner's club and
I want to thank you guys for [__]
being here with us today before we leave
do not forget CBD lion listen I've been
working with these guys I've been using
their products for a long time
and any element I have a sore foot
whatever my ball sack is purple I rub
any CBD Lion's product from the tincture
to the cream to the listen they got some
bath balls you put in the tub you wake
up the next day feeling like a [__]
Savage so go to CBD line right now look
at the third party lab results read read
about CBD CBN and get your [__] together
if you want to order some CBD pressing
code Joey joint a church and get 20 off
your first order the joint is also
brought to you by DraftKings listen to
me the fight is live from New York City
this week it's 281 and it's going
[__] down new customers you bet five
dollars on any UFC 281 fight and I'm
going to give you 200 and free bets when
your fighter wins who's better than
Uncle Joey nobody who's better than
[__] DraftKings nobody not in the
faction for you let me tell you
something DraftKings has prop bets
that'll make you [__] her curl they
got a hundred percent boost on
DraftKings stepped up parlay so place a
parlay with three or more picks and
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will win and total rounds I love the guy
Joe perea whatever his name is I think
he's gonna rattle [__] Israel a
little bit he's getting too big for his
[__] boxing Rings there anyway
DraftKings Sportsbook is the only place
Uncle Joey bets on the UFC so download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app today use
promo code Joey throw down five dollars
on UFC 281 and get 200 and free bets if
your fighter wins in that 200 in free
bets you got your [__] bankroll built
up already that's code Joey this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details that's
it and that's that I want to thank CBD
lion I want to thank [__] uh what's
the name of this company that's
tremendous I'm feeling a lot better now
I want to thank CBD lion DraftKings and
my main people over there at heart and
soil stay black have a great weekend and
we'll see you [__] Monday morning
Tip Top Magoo
[Music]